and finally new rule if you look like
you've got to stick up your ass you
you've probably got to stick up your ass
[Applause]
when President Hellboy first dug William
bar out of the garage pundits said Oh at
least this one's normal
he's an indoor Republican but now the
pundits are asking how could this smart
normal person fall under the Trump spell
so fast we thought he was old school an
institutionalist what happened to Bill
Barr I'll tell you what happened in 1950
he was born into a strange cult and he's
never been able to leave it's called
Catholicism
[Applause]
that's the secret to why Bill Barr was
so anxious to become Donald Trump's
loyal hand he's just the latest in a
long line of Republican Catholic
moralizer z-- who actually believed well
here's Barr in 1995 we have lived
through 30 years of permissiveness the
sexual revolution and the drug culture
the greatest threat to free government
the founders believed was not
governmental tyranny but personal
licentiousness you see Barr knows Trump
wants to be a dictator but who cares
it's not about tyranny
it's about tits bar once wrote in
Catholic lawyer magazine
worst swimsuit issue ever the founders
believed the choice was clear we could
govern ourselves guided by religion and
morality or we could lose our Liberty
altogether yes they believed it's so
strongly they wrote it down nowhere
there is nothing about morality in the
Constitution it's like Jesus on the
subject of butt sex it ain't in there
it's in here permissiveness
licentiousness drug culture I've heard
these words and listen to the same
horseshit my whole life this creepy
substrain of Catholic conservatives who
think limited government means
government should put a limit on
people's sex lives Sean Hannity Bill
O'Reilly Rick Santorum who predicted gay
marriage would lead to man-dog marriage
give it really Pat Buchanan bill Bennett
with his book of virtues Robert Bork
Newt Gingrich geez law and order special
virgins unit
it's almost like there's a religious war
going on in this country there is a
religious war going on in this country
see and then there's the Supreme Court
the country is 21% Catholic but the
court is 67 percent Catholic including
Clarence Thomas and his batshit wife
Ginny and until recently their mentor
Antonin Scalia who was really hardcore
I mean Mel Gibson's dad level Kathleen
Scalia once said if we're up to me I
would put in jail every sandal-wearing
scruffy bearded weirdo who burns the
American flag yes because we can never
trust two sandal-wearing scruffy bearded
weirdo
maybe one and now we have Brett
Kavanaugh he of the landmark case tastes
great versus less filling
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he's another one of these in the 90s he
wrote the Starr report and he wanted it
to be about Bill Clinton's he said
Clinton had disgraced his office the
legal system in American people by
having sex with a 22 year old and it's
our job to make his pattern of revolting
behavior clear piece by painful piece
Jesus he's not just mad he wasn't
invited to the party's mad there is a
party
[Applause]
these are people who have a real problem
with unsanctioned pleasure and growing
up Catholic myself I know a lot of it
stems are being taught not to masturbate
as a teenager you've got Jesus on the
cross in your bedroom staring at you all
the time when you touch yourself there
he is disappointed it's like you're
crucifying him all over again
[Laughter]
the Catholic Church is very good at
pretending it's modernizing a Pope will
change the rule about no meet on Friday
or say a theist can get into heaven like
we care but the hardcore inquisitors
never go away and they think their job
is to protect the Republican Party at
all costs so it can fight the real enemy
hippies shown here in 1969 and on a
continuous loop in Republican heads
it's the 50th anniversary of Woodstock
this summer and conservatives need to be
told that's all it is it's not the
anniversary of when everything went to
because some kids got high and got
laid and God didn't punish them they
just had to listen to sha na na
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes there was a sexual revolution and
you lost
now stop bitching about it because bill
Barr
he's that guy Woodstock ruined America
now put prayer back in school or I'll
never stop dreaming about this guy's
dick
you